it is unacceptable in this country to
have illegal
votes counted and that is what is
happening
in the state of nevada strong
accusations from the trump campaign as
they plan to file a federal lawsuit
against the state
and clark county republicans claim the
county is counting
thousands of illegal ballots but did not
present
evidence of widespread voter fraud
sources telling our 8 news now i-team
there is
no evidence of widespread fraud the
i-team's david charns joining us now
with more about this latest lawsuit
david
so at five o'clock now this lawsuit has
yet to be filed now eight hours
after that 9 a.m news conference let's
break it down here for you the trump
campaign
and state republicans allege ten
thousand people who voted here in nevada
no longer live here they also say there
are votes that are using dead people's
names
and again an allegation here they say
there are voters who moved here inside
that 30-day
residency requirement window making them
ineligible to vote however
the campaign provided not one piece of
evidence
about any of these claims
they continue to count illegal
votes that is unacceptable
and it's giving legal people
a sense that the system is corrupt
now there were two people who spoke at
this news conference this morning one
was a man who said he was from a
conservative media outlet
and he said he couldn't record the count
on election night and he was told to
leave when everything closed down
in the middle of the morning we tried to
track him down today but
could not find him the second person who
spoke was jill stokey now you may
remember her we broke her story back on
monday
she's legally blind and she showed us
the device she uses to help her see
she says when she went to go vote in
person she was told her mail-in ballot
had been
sent and the signatures matched but
stokey is adamant
that she did not vote as you heard her
just say there
and believes the ballot was stolen now
in today's news conference stokey
mentioned us here at channel 8 saying
that i had told her reid received emails
and calls about voting inconsistencies
i told stokey when i interviewed her and
the i-team has now repeatedly reported
voter fraud is extremely rare and our
sources are telling us
there is no widespread coordinated
effort of voter fraud here
the i-team has reported over and over
there is no fraud in
nevada we've looked at the signature
verification process and we've told you
how those have to match as well there's
a machine that does that that's part of
the reason why this is taking so much
time
we also told you out of more than 7
million votes that have been now cast
in nevada elections since 2008 just
two votes out of more than 7 million are
known to have been cast
illegally and that was by the same
person in 2008
and 2010 however remember this is the
first election now where
counties sent mail-in ballots to
everybody
even if they didn't want one that's 1.8
million
registered voters more next at six
o'clock i'm david charns 8 news now